so what I'm going to talk about today is
the science of learning technology and
transformation in higher education so
I'm going to start and I'm going to
start where I imagine good HCI people
always start so if we're talking about
learning we're going to start with the
learner so I worked in higher I'm a kind
of an outlier in the Graduate School of
Education because I worked in higher
education most of my colleagues work in
k-12 education and I work not just in
higher education at Stanford but I work
with institutions of higher education of
all what we would call Carnegie
classification Ackley across the country
but to some extent internationally as
well
and one of the things that every
institution of higher education is
observing is the tasks that we're being
given which is not only to educate more
students larger number of students in
higher education but a greater diversity
of students and I don't just mean
diversity in terms of racial ethnic
cultural religious gender identity
sexual orientation all the different
usual classifications of diversity those
are all important but also diversity in
their background knowledge they're
relevant skills and their future goals
so if how many of you are teaching right
now in higher education okay so one of
the things you may have observed is that
in your classes the students that are
coming into your classes not only have
varying degrees of preparation for what
they need to be able to affect if we do
what you need them to do so their skills
are varied but also their goals the
reason they're even sitting in that
class so we have this incredible
diversity in the needs goals abilities
of the students the other diversity
which we study more of here at Stanford
is also the meaning that they make out
of the learning experience you give them
so you can't just sort of say if you do
this then the learner will make this
meaning out of it because
very complex that process so we need to
look at all of this diversity now how
many of you think about have heard about
educational I guess in fighting our
arguments about what's the most
effective way to teach someone something
Oh Sookie if you haven't heard I'll give
you a little insight into some of these
arguments you'll hear them a lot one of
them is when you're talking about
teaching someone like I don't know
computer science is it better to give
them some basic instruction a lot of
practice doing the basics or is it
better to give them really complex
challenging tasks so that they get a
deeper conceptual understanding like
that's a kind of dichotomy that is often
presented so which is better
it depends okay so let you decide that
is the emphasis see Michael knows it
depends so so you might say but you have
to just make a choice like when you're
designing something you have to make a
choice so you make a choice let's say
you say I'm going to give them more help
with the basics then I have to fight how
am I going to give them help it might be
any different focused practice
distributed practice gradually widen the
practice so I have to make that choice
once I decide I'm going to give them
help with the basic focused practice
then what kind of practice am I going to
give them am I going to give them work
examples to study am i giving them
problems to solve am i going to do some
kind of internally blend and so on I
won't run you through all of this but
the point is that any choice you make
quickly grows exponentially
all those little micro decisions you
have to make to decide how to
personalize the learning to that learner
so if you imagine as an instructor
you're making this decision very rapidly
for not just one student but for this
big diversity of students I was just
talking about so that's
kind of a challenge so what a lot of
people are talking about is that our
current processes for doing that the way
we've done higher education for years
doesn't really work anymore and my
argument whenever Inside Higher
Education or the chronicle of Education
or any of those newspapers write about
my work they always have some kind of
headline which is she's trying to
replace us with computers and what I
mean I used to respond to that in the
following way frankly any faculty member
who can be replaced by a computer should
be but it didn't exactly have the impact
I was hoping it would have people didn't
quite understand what I meant what I
meant was what a faculty member does is
so complex and nuanced that if all
they're doing is what I can do with a
computer and actually they should be
replaced what I meant was also that the
tools the tasks that were given as
faculty to do is not doable with the
current set of tools and in higher
education and other institutions where
there's these increasingly constrained
resources collapsing time collapsing
resources greater diversity of students
more students achieve these outcomes in
this different resource environments
it's an unfair task unless we have
better tools and supports for the
learners and for the instructors to do
that and that's in essence what I'm
trying to build as I think I learned
today some of the students in the
seminar are also trying to build so I
know you have been thinking about this
question people talk a lot about
technology and how it's going to
transform education and so I want to
just take a poll of where you're where
this groups thinking is around what's
going to transform education and usually
when I ask what's the big power of the
technology is it's going to trance
for education I get one of three answers
these three the first one this is the
big MOOC phenomena right access and
convenience with a computer learning
online you can learn anytime anyplace
huge transformative power access and to
other people special people who've been
watching my work saying nnf it's about
this it's about that you can do things
with a computer that you can't do in a
human classroom system like if we're
trying to teach someone how to build a
bridge we can put them in a really great
simulation where they build the bridge
it collapses nobody dies but they can
have that experience simulation the
third one is now tennis it's not about
the individual and interacting with the
computer it's about that these computers
are connected to the Internet and by
connecting to the internet it's about
connecting connecting the learners to
other learners connecting learners to
other experts connecting the learners to
the world so now I'm going to make you
guys vote for one of these but if you
have to put your money on which of these
is the big power the big affordance of
the technology that's going to transform
education what would you vote Higher
Education us you can define the context
okay so how many people think it's
access inconvenience that's the big
power okay how many people think the
simulation capability okay great how
many people think a snows connection
crap okay we've got nice distribution
here how many are thinking wait I
thought Michael said that you were from
the Graduate School of Education why are
you giving us a crummy multiple-choice
test
how many you wanted to say all of the
above okay how many of you just don't
raise your hands when you're asked to
raise your hand okay how many of you
wanted to say none of the above
okay me yeah actually I say all of the
above and none of the above but I'm
interested what's your none of the above
what's the power that I didn't mention
Oh
what is you could make education free
what if you could pay people to say okay
so open free yeah I kind of boiled out a
little bit into access or communion
anything else on that admission and
experience here no it's very fun
intuition and experience explanation
okay simulation is experiential
knowledge okay so you guys are refining
some of my categories that's great okay
so I agree all of these are important
but actually this isn't the biggest I
don't think this is the biggest power
the biggest power of this technology is
what Google has already figured out it's
what Netflix has already figured out
it's what Amazon has already figured out
the power of this technology is not
using it just push it out to people but
to push it to the interface why what can
we do at the interface we can observe
the learner Netflix Google Amazon they
are observing us in their interface all
the time why why does Google care what
I'm doing in the browser interface yeah
to customize so then to sell now yes
those two things to learn about me as a
consumer both me as an individual
consumer so they can target product at
me better but also to learn about
consumers in general so they can come up
with better marketing strategies so I'm
talking about using that same approach
but not looking at learners as consumers
looking at them as learners so in the
interface we can collect data to observe
the learner to understand the learner
better as an individual but also to
understand learners and learning
collectively better that's the power of
this technology that we can collect the
student interaction data and drive very
powerful feedback loops to multiple
actors in the teaching and learning
system so back to the learner that's
what the instructor back to the
designers of the technology and then
back to the learning researchers and
I'll just quickly give a little example
or powered each so with the learner we
know that for example one of the things
we know from learning research is rather
than just lecturing at learners giving
them a goal giving them directed pede
feedback and giving them practice
enhances learning so we can give them
all kinds of interesting authentic tasks
give them feedback based on how they're
performing across multiple tasks we can
also not just do it to build procedural
skills but also to build conceptual
understanding like being able to take a
bunch of discrete skills synthesize them
and apply them in a new context oh this
is in a chemistry course but I'm not
going to go into great detail cuz I want
to get to the discussion part the other
feedback is to the instructor so if a
learner is interacting with
well-designed
learning activities and we're collecting
the data from the students interactions
then we can model that data to give the
instructor insight into where their
students are so the instructor can use
that information to plan their class
type that makes sense
so the first and just this is what we're
going to be working on a little bit
later but our first attempt at doing
that when I was back at Carnegie Mellon
was to build these instructor dashboards
so this is a natural instructor
dashboard generated off of an
introductory statistics course so and
this is a dashboard that's from an
actual class so the first thing is this
module had six articulated learning
outcomes and the bar to the site of them
of the outcome tells the instructor for
your class what's our prediction about
the knowledge state of your of your
students so Green would tell us they got
it if you were to give them an
assessment today they would nail that
task orange says it's kind of moderate
red says they're struggling they don't
get it what do you think gray means not
yet attempted or not attempted enough
they haven't done enough for our
modeling approach to make a reliable
prediction they could have done some
tasks they just haven't done enough yeah
boundaries of what this is because I
love it I'm just reflecting on why I'm
teaching it in sort of a design studio
of course in some ways it might be
similar to like an English course where
maybe the learning objective might be
something around like understanding you
know Thoros relationship with that and
it's not the kind of thing where like
simulated exercises can first of all you
can design a little bit but it's a
they're indirect and part and can live a
lot of them I'm wondering what
opportunities are there for these much
more sort of indirect learning goals
that sort you deserve but maybe in sort
of a larger project level yes so
different here Michaels question okay so
I would push back on you in a couple of
ways one of them is when you say I want
them to understand whatever it was you
said I can you know
the explicit learning will help students
go beyond drug called circus well maybe
finding where when when they engage with
music they come back and say something
like oh the button if they say why are
they doing that system in the first
place whether they need to cetera okay
and that can be observed when they come
back which can you have a result but if
I were to produce some sort of
multiple-choice quizzes so the answer is
owing obvious like by Foley's look I
tell you the point you you know what
once when the actual proficiency added
is much more efficient oh they don't
hear that so what I would do with
Michael if he were of faculty domain
expert that I was working with is I
would ask I would when he comes at me
with a understand learning goal we would
need to unpack what do you mean by
understand I will say that I was
involved in a project with the Carnegie
Foundation of the street developing this
statway courseware for developmental for
students replacing developmental math
and an alternative pathway going through
as statistics as the terminal course
instead of and so they wisely brought
together multiple faculty from multiple
institutions to define the learning
outcomes what is it by the end of going
through this course we want students to
be able to do it now and they had three
meetings two days each to bring faculty
together to articulate this I
unfortunately cuz my travel schedule
missed the first two meetings but was
there for the third meeting and when by
the time I showed up they were like oh
it's great we've got it done we've
articulated the learning outcomes now we
can just start talking about tonight I'm
like great
can I see them can I see the outcomes
and they were things like understand
understand computer stand medians or
design modes the center really models
have sent the definitions of center and
spread okay great
so can I ask what you mean by understand
you all you all know what you mean oh
yeah we totally we've talked about it we
know so then I started to ask okay so
you when you say they understand
measures of center do you mean that if
you
did a bunch of terms they could say
which ones are measures the center if
you gave them you could you asked them
one of the three major measures of
center and how would you define them is
that what you mean yeah that would be
great okay great you is that what you
mean well no you know I want them to be
able to you know recognize when you use
I mean versus a median versus a mode
okay that's different okay so being able
to clearly articulate what the learning
goal actually is and then some way to
get at that is how would you observe it
so sometimes what I do with faculty when
they can't get past the understand I'll
say Penda so that understand abetted us
so that and you gave me a so that so
then we can start to develop tasks not
necessarily multiple-choice questions
but tasks that we can observe movement
in an interface that would collect
evidence about the degree to which the
student had that particular had achieved
that outcome so one of the differences
is like in in like Khan Academy I'll
pick on it they have they say they have
a particular idea about how to assess
mastery or competence which is usually I
have if so let's say the goal is the
students should be able to compute the
median I'll stay with my statistics
example so they'll say okay I'm going to
give you ten arrays of numbers and I'm
going to ask you for those ten arrays of
numbers to compute the median ten times
if you get out eight out of the 10 times
or eight in a row I'll say you know how
to compute the median move on okay so
that's one way of but that's kind of it
doesn't get out what you're talking
about because what we really mean is
when we say a student we want to make
sure students can compute the median is
that yeah they can compute the median
but you want to know can they recognize
if they're given a data set and they're
asked some questions can't do they know
when computing the median is going to
actually help them make traction on
answering the question they're trying to
the larger question they're trying to
answer
so can they use computing the median as
a tool do they know when to use it
then once they say okay I should compute
the median here as opposed to computing
the mean or the mode then do I know how
to compute the median or do I make some
common mistakes like I forget to put the
numbers in a rank order before I pick
the center number or whatever the issue
is or I mistake the median for the mode
or whatever then once I've computed the
median do I know what to do with that
number to make meaning on my original
task so those are all three what I would
call knowledge components that get put
into a really simple articulation of
compute the median and what we would do
in the kinds of courseware that I'm
developing is we would give students
multiple opportunities in all kinds of
tasks where compute the median is a sub
step and we don't say okay now we're
computing the median can you do it we
just observe when they get it would have
been logical when they're at that point
and trying to solve this more complex
task that what they would do is compute
the median and whether they do or don't
or whether they ask for a hand to
whether they you know what they do then
we get insight into where they are in
that learning trajectory of achieving
that outcome either he's a student a
long time to answer whatever this thing
would be that might be so money
difficult to get a good estimate of
their of their understanding or the
heart is where assess what they produce
so it takes maybe and maybe it requires
someone with a lot expertise an area to
manually label it are there ways that if
you play with this so this is one of the
areas of active research right so our
approach historically has been getting
together domain experts with learning
researchers with software engineers with
data modelers that all work together to
Co construct the intervention and then
think about what evidence does that
produce but the real power is if you
could if you create these kinds of
activities intentionally that way then
you can have as I do
thousands of learner
using them in all kinds of different
contexts and you can begin to use the
data to start to answer some of those
questions so they might be expensive to
produce on the front end but then on the
back end on the y youth then the per
student cost gets very small
for example learners do not always have
sufficient mastery to be able to
recognize when another student has
succeeded at a path which makes me
evaluation of the assessment actually
difficult to scale right right which
means that I can't easily get these bar
graphs so maybe I maybe I have a lack of
creativity here I will show you yeah so
this is this is great because this is
like where we can get some active
research so the thing that we this was
our first representation so the way that
the the way that this prediction is made
is are all these different activities
that are designed for which that larger
outcome relate measures with center and
spread to the shape of a distribution
and choose the appropriate measure in
different contexts there are multiple
tasks and subtasks throughout an entire
module where everywhere the student
didn't necessarily know but the system
knows that's what we're looking at so
it's sort of semantically that task is
semantically tagged and so then we can
make a prediction for where your classes
but also where each student is but that
has everything to do with how well does
our predictive model work so the other
thing that we do is the first model that
we build to make these predictions that
we use the experts and so on to build we
call that a naive model because it's
just what we what the domain experts the
learning researchers bought the
association was between those tasks and
the prediction
the problem requires skills so if they
got it right there's some evidence or
they go that's right and there's a
underlying which we'll talk about in a
moment there are different ways of this
we're getting into knowledge tracing now
and there are different models you can
use to trace knowledge so as for this
one we were using a pretty simple four
parameter Bayesian knowledge tracing
model a hidden Markov model and so but
there are other other models that people
put forward that they believe will make
better predictions so in the new system
that we're building that the model is
interchangeable but we'll talk about
that in a minute but yes so so that's
but and then once we get all this data
from thousands of students using these
activities we can then look at how well
does our model fit the data and then
recognize where there are places where
the model needs to be updated like for
example if we've labeled a bunch of
tasks compute the median but in fact
where they were struggling we do like a
learning curve analysis and we could see
a nicely downward sloping learning curve
and then an inflection point where it
flattens out then you could say okay
what's going on there oh that's not
really just compute the median that's
recognized when to compute the median so
then we can unpack and refine the
knowledge model this is as the x-axis is
going up this is now you have a better
students to the right or to the left so
for a classic sort of learning curve is
the y-axis is the amount of assistance
the learner needed in order to achieve
that task the x-axis is the number of
opportunities to demonstrate that task
the knowledge the knowledge component
what we call a knowledge component so so
if you think about it what you really
want is I'm not a good learning curve is
one that starts high and then slopes
nicely downward because what that means
is when that learner was first
confronted with AK asked where they
needed this hypothetical knowledge
component in order to achieve it they
needed a lot of support either they
tried answering it they got
back or they asked for a hint or
something and then over time as they
were given more and more and more and
more cash opportunities to demonstrate
that knowledge they needed fewer and
fewer supports to demonstrate it yes x's
opportunities number of opportunities
which is in theory yes in time sure sure
and so anyway so what you can do is
start to look at how well does your
predictive model actually fit the data
and look for these inflection points for
these flattening out points where you
know you need to refine your model okay
so I'm going to skip through all of this
because I want to get to so I so this is
like oh actually I'm not gonna skip this
part so what I said was in the old
system or in the current system we bring
together these development teams but
then we also now as I said have hundreds
of faculty that are using these course
works to support their teaching and when
I developed the system at Carnegie
Mellon we did not have authoring tools
so the kind of choice was use what we
designed or don't or join our
development team and add stuff and so
one of the things that we have in moving
to open EDX here at Stanford is
authoring tools but that then created
this additional problem which is now
people make an instance with the course
make their modifications and it's you
know so now we have like 50 different
versions of the courseware and we don't
get a way of actually using the data to
drive the continuous improvement but I
have a solution for that which I'll not
talk about right now talk about it later
okay then the science of learning which
so so the purpose of the science
learning is basically just describe
predict explain human learning and that
particular science is the one that I
used a lot when I was at Carnegie Mellon
is cognitive science taking these very
complex cognitive tasks like doing data
analysis or writing a computer program
and essentially deconstructing it into
different components and then building
guided learning experiences with hints
and feedback to support works but then
here at Stanford I now have whole new
set of colleagues so I look at things
not just cognitively but also social
psychologically like what's the learners
mindset and how does that intersect
we're doing some interesting research
right now with inserting into the
statistics course we're different
experiments around mindset interventions
and also building effect detectors and
timing the delivery of the mindset
intervention not just to the cognitive
complexity but also to the affective
state of the learner and that again will
help us both refine our theory of how
mindset works along with helping
learners actually learn and then also
issues of social belongingness or
stereotype threat which I don't have
time to really going to invest but let's
say other factors that you need to be
looking at when you're looking at the
learner experiences the interest there
is looking at this is horrible looking
at the environment and say what are the
cues explicit or implicit in the
environment that trigger or mitigate
stereotype threat to a particular
learning and can we manipulate cues in
the environment that will address that
use are yes I can't control yet I can't
control the whole learning environment
so the environment that I can control I
mean a small example of that is just a
small example of that is you know in
facebook when they used to have the the
icon they had of was it friends icon it
had a male and a female and the male was
in front and bigger and the female was
smaller and behind and that little cue I
mean I'm sure it wasn't designed in any
way to communicate anything but it does
and so if you manipulate those kinds of
cues and signals in the environment can
you change the experience of stereotypes
so it's just another lens to look at the
design through okay so and this is of
course data science so now we have all
of our learning theory and then we have
all of our new data tools and we bring
those together the bottom up from data
driven top down from Theory driven with
the subject matter experts to build
better explanatory and predictive models
that we use to design the environment so
I was going to talk about how we do
learning research but I'm going to skip
that because I want to get to what I
really want to talk about and yeah this
is another so what I was talking about
is the data collection and analysis in
real-time and another project I have an
NSF project is to build the backend data
infrastructure to support learning
researchers to be able to use each
other's data and do analysis over
multiple institutions but and yeah this
is the idea is that when we're doing
learning research we should be working
in pastures quadrants are you familiar
with this matrix so this was a way of
looking at sites that there are two
dimensions either science that has a
high emphasis on basic science on
fundamental understanding with a low
emphasis on practical use and if you're
working in high emphasis on basic
science low emphasis on applied work
then you're actually working in fourth
quadrant this was kind of based on
physics
so Niels Bohr's so you're developing and
understanding fundamental principles but
how you translate or use those in the
real world isn't a focus or you could be
working in Edison's quadrant which is
really applied how do I solve this
problem with very little focus on what
fundamental principles are redeveloping
so the problem there is how do you solve
this problem but how do you get some
meta understanding that will help you
solve the next problem
and then there is this quadrant which I
didn't put a name on it actually Stokes
did put a name on it he called it
Peterson quadrant
anybody know who Peterson was he's a
bird book
Peterson's guide to Burt North American
birds no bird watchers in here anyway
it's it's low in fences on basic science
low infant son applied work it is
essentially following the researchers
curiosity that was the idea I simply
tell my students what n F NSF will not
fund so just stay out of that quadrant
and then we're I believe learning
research needs to be is up here in
pastures quadrant where we have were
constructing interventions we construct
the research so that we are
simultaneously making progress on our
fundamental understanding of human
learning at the same time that we're
solving a real-world learning or
educational challenge and then this gets
to the virtuous cycle that Michael was
talking about which is we start with our
current learning theories and our
current ways modeling data we use that
to inform the design of the learning
experience we design the learning
experience mediated by the technology to
do what the technology does best we just
collect data we analyze that data to
refine our learning theory and models to
redesign the environment and we set up
this virtuous cycle of continuous
improvement and that's my argument for
why it's the data collection capacity
that is really the big power that's
going to transform education okay
so why this has happen in higher
education and I said to the lunch group
it's because higher education is in this
enviable position in which the
researchers the practitioners and those
that are intended to benefit from the
research and practice the students are
all co-located so we can rapidly design
interventions collect the data and
iterate very rapidly and now I'll just
end with two quotes before I give you
your task the first quote is from if
you've ever been to Carnegie Mellon you
have to quote herb Simon
he's like our our little luminary and he
said back in 1991 improvement in
post-secondary education will require
converting teaching from a solo sport to
a community-based research activity
now I modified his quote sorry herb to
change it to improvement in
post-secondary education will require
converting teaching and courseware and
platform and analytic system development
from a solo sport to a community-based
research activity and my last quote is
from another economist William Baumol
who said back in 1967 without a complete
revolution in our approach to teaching
we cannot go beyond our current levels
of productivity when I need to give this
quote I used to say such a revolution is
possible now I say such a revolution is
happening not only possible it's
actually occurring but my question is
the same if we'll having this revolution
who will lead it and it's kind of an
embedded advocacy which is I think
institutions like Stanford need to be
painting this in an interdisciplinary
way but we can talk about okay
so that was all I was going to tell you
before I give you your task to do do you
any questions so you can open this a
little bit earlier on so there's a lot
going on in the head tech states right
now you know an industry outside of
academia you know maybe you just have to
photo in your last comment book what do
you think of all that and a teepee
the Joshua players playing into what
you're like so different here question
okay
so I am both excited by and terrified by
what's happening in the investment in
EdTech world for a long time nobody was
investing really in EdTech because there
wasn't a lot of money in it but now
because of these hours that we're
talking about it's being recognized that
there is potentially a lot of money in
it so there's a lot of VC funding
happening and I should preface this by
saying some of my best friends are
venture capitalists some of my best
friends are EdTech developers so it's
not that I'm dissing them but I would
argue that the the major outcome driver
might be not quite compatible with the
major outcome goal of not-for-profit
higher education a lot of my friends
that are DC's when they're investing in
these and tech startups they're looking
for a 30 times return on investment why
because they know most of what they
invest in isn't going to hit so when you
when something hits you want it to hit
and return your investment and most of
them are not looking for immediate
profitability what are they looking for
what's the big marker right now anybody
I didn't get revenue growth and I'm not
sure but how many people are using this
thing because then because if we can get
a lot a big user base that's where the
money is going to be so unfortunately
what it's driving a lot of my friends in
the ed tech startup business even if
they have something that's kind of
innovative and interesting they quickly
have to satisfice to the market because
the market but decision making process
is still different and they so that so
their innovation kind of gets tweaked
and tweaked and tweaked and tweaked till
it fits better what the market who's
making a buying decision wants which is
not it's not a recipe for driving
innovation it's a recipe for satisficing
to the market so that's one of my big
concerns the other big concern is that
the data that we're collecting the
models that were making from the data
and the predictions and the explanations
that are extracted from those models
support pedagogical decision-making in
one of two ways either giving it back to
the system itself in how many people
have heard of personalized and adaptive
learning environments it's a big thing
making personalized learning an adaptive
learning environment what that means is
from the interactions as I was talking
about from the learner
then you model that make a prediction
about the learner and based on that
prediction
the system itself decides what to give
the learner next the challenge there
look at the challenges one of them is to
differentiate instruction which is what
we're talking about you have to have
some reasonable sense of on what basis
what makes this learner different than
this learner for the purposes of this
differentiation decision and we don't
really have right now a good taxonomy if
you will of how factors about a learner
factors about the knowledge factors
about the environment interact in ways
that would support a reasonable
differentiation decision you could argue
that you don't need that anymore what
you can do is just get a huge amount of
data and just give it and just train a
learner and in this case I mean a
machine not a human train a learner on
that data and it doesn't have to be able
to faster to sort of define what the
different factors are it just has to
make a very reliable prediction so it
doesn't matter what that what
differentiates these different learners
as long as we can make an accurate
prediction about what's going to give
them what to give them next to get to
where you want them to go but the bias
there someone who's working on bias and
that that I talked to at lunch anyway
the bias there is what data are you
training the model on and what are the
outcomes that you're giving it to train
against
so you know see we see it in other
sectors where we risk if we're just
giving huge amounts of data that is not
representative of what we're trying to
achieve that we're going to instantiate
in the learning processes all of the
exhibit and tool it in all of the
existing biases that are in our
education system and that terrifies me
what I think the real power is is let's
go ahead and let train the machines to
identify the patterns but then we should
critically look at those patterns and
say is that what we're really trying to
reproduce before we just give it to a
system to to instantiate that in
replicated scale so and I just worry
that the motivation what's driving
because I used to work in the private
sector before as an academic I was a I
was in the private sector and people
always say to me you know Candice it's
not like commercial companies are all
evil there are some really good ones out
there there are ethical ones out there
like I know but I also know having been
in the private sector that the number
one ethic that is returned shareholder
value and that has to be the primary
driver and if you're not making that
your primary driver you are actually
behaving unethically and so when that
two flicks with other goals then I think
it puts institutions in a hard
organizations in a hard position other
questions
hi Lee so far I want you to try to
convince me that in all in those
situations it's possible to develop a
model of the learner and a knowledge
that is intentionally measurable I'll
give you an example if I'm trying to
teach class musicians how to program and
my learning goal is that it seems to be
able to design a murmuring some sort of
interaction they want to have an atomic
produced and then drew some means of
programming implement it without too
much difficulty and have an intense
what they've done I could divide that
and the knowledge components like
student identifier worth using array and
they know how to access an array and
they know we not to go beyond the MZ
array but if I don't actually care about
which language features they learn I
just wanted to have a satisfying
experience I'm not sure I read correctly
down that so I'm going to respond in a
couple ways one of them is and if I did
say this I misspoke
I didn't mean measurable I meant
observable so measure implies ranking
that you can say this person is better
than this person is better than this
person is better than this person so
some kind of ranking that's implied in
measurement I don't need for the
evidence I'm collecting to be able to
allow me to rank order learners but I
but it does need to be observable so I
can get insight into what are they doing
so that that's my first thing the second
thing is remember the headline she's
trying to replace us with computers
I'm not what I'm trying to do is say
there are things that the technology
does really really well there are things
there affordances to the technology
there are affordances to what a learner
can do with their peers
can do with an expert and they all eat
them if you think of those as resources
in a design space they all have
limitations and they all have
affordances and what I'm trying to build
is given the constraints of our current
whatever the context is in which you're
teaching and learning and those
resources you can bring to bear how do
you make an intelligent decision about
how to blend those different resources
in a way that creates the best learning
experience we can at that point in time
for that learner at the same time is
learning something about how to make
that design decision better next time so
I wouldn't try and all those things that
you're trying to achieve I wouldn't say
let's try and figure out how to make a
computer do all of this I would say
let's take what parts of those is real
the learner is actually better supported
and we can get better information from
mediating with the technology in which
plate which things do we need to keep as
a design that we do with the learners
interacting with each other or with you
as the expert but I do think that we can
do a lot more than what most people
think I think most people think all you
can do is if you can give me a multiple
choice question assess it right or wrong
that's what a computer is good Act
there's I mean there there's a lot more
you can do like like one of my doctoral
students who just got her PhD she was
working with the poetic Media Lab here
on this piece of technology called
lacunae stories and what that does is it
allows literature or anytime you have
something you're reading you load it
into lacuna stories and then your
students as they're reading make
annotations either by highlighting or by
adding comments or whatever and so what
she was building was a automated system
that could give insight so we have
learners using that at sort of Foothill
DeAnza Michigan at Stanford in all kinds
of different classes and one of the
things and so faculty can see where the
hotspots are that's some information but
if the information was pretty
overwhelming for faculty to try and
parse and figure out okay what do I do
with this to do something different in
class with this new insight and so we
started to code annotations by whether
they were reflective of a student making
a comprehension a reading comprehension
kind of move or a analysis kind of move
so like what the stance was of learner
and could we train an algorithm to be
able to automatically with a high level
of reliability to tech those kind of
move so we can say to an instructor you
know at this point in time on this text
this percentage of your students are
still just trying to understand
comprehend with the reading and this is
where but know now if you're they're
moving into analysis and you could have
and you could have a trajectory over
time where a faculty member could try
different interventions that they're
trying to move their learners from more
fewer comprehension moves to more
analytic moves and then you could tell
were those interventions
we helping move the learners along that
trajectory so there are other ways than
just intelligent tutoring systems that
we can use the technology to collect
observable information to support
teaching and learning there's one over
there okay I broke my promise I said I
was answer short okay so okay any other
questions should I give you your task
because there is a task okay because you
guys are all HCI you men and women are
all HCI people right men and women and
yeah okay so your subjective here's our
goal okay so give data-driven feedback
to instructors on their student progress
that instructors use to make informed
decisions in their classroom okay that's
what we're trying to come up with okay
the student progress data comes from the
oli courseware in the or system the open
analytic system the instructor is the
user and we want to data driven so we
want them to use the data that we're
collecting and this is what the or from
the open analytics research system is
that we built okay so it takes right now
in EDX and Lagunitas ooh class here it
also an event handler that throws four
pieces of information from every student
interaction it throws the student ID the
component ID what thing they're
interacting with the time and date stamp
and a value between 0 and 1 it also
sends the learner and course information
ahead of time to the system we have a
skill mapping service where all of those
components are associated with skills
the skills are associated with learning
outcomes and then that information goes
into a modeling service where you can
use different predictive modeling
approaches like Bayesian knowledge
tracing deep knowledge tracing and then
that output of that model gets sent to
learner activity recommendation service
or visualization service which then
either
deliver directly out of orders as it is
right now or fed back into the learning
management system if the learning
management system can receive it to
either adapt and personalize the
learning or to present a instructor
dashboard stays that clear okay how much
time do we have
oh no time Oh bummer okay well you can
work on it and come to me I want you to
work on this because what the task is is
so I was going to explain how the
severity all these activities they feed
these skills which then roll up to these
learning objectives well we're not going
to have time to do this so bummer okay
because this has been a great oh sure
okay so so this is just sort of showing
how it it goes I was going to okay
so right now these I showed you one
visualization another visualization that
we came up with was this one that shows
this is like at a skill level this is
like a class of 225 learners it shows us
the number of activities done by the
students is the x-axis and then the
number of activities done by the
students who have not yet mastered the
skill that's along the x-axis but the
downside so mastered not mastered up and
down and then why did we create that
because what I was finding with the old
dashboard that I showed you a
registering prediction is when I had
asked when we watch we need observe in
the data how faculty were using it they
knew that if they we started off giving
them a prediction about knowledge state
and they learned quickly where to find
how many problems did the student do so
they would like not we could tell by the
kind delay they weren't looking at that
first display at all they were just
cooking in to find out what they wanted
to know which is I assigned 20 problems
how many problems the students do so
we're trying to come up with a different
visual representation that would drive
the faculty behavior support the
behavior they currently have but drive
them towards
different behavior which is using
evidence of student knowledge to inform
their decision-making instead of just
their old measures which are how did you
do what I told you to do okay so and we
did this by asking them you know what
the instructors need to make informed
decisions for class and the instructor
would say I need to know if the students
could be assigned 20 activities and we'd
ask them why do you need to know that
and then they say if they did the
homework then they must have mastered
the skill they did what I told them to
do then they would have learned it and
so then we'd say so you need to know if
the students mastered the skill that's
really what you're trying to get at but
even if they table yeah they still want
that first piece of evidence so one of
the challenges that that they need to
first that we're discovering is that
they first they need to know students
answered activities with an estimate of
whether or not the students have
mastered an assigned skill but we have
other more accurate ways of estimating
this for them so why do they still want
that and one there is that the dashboard
isn't bitonic convinced they don't
really believe that it makes a better
prediction that they would make which I
heartily agree with that skepticism and
that's why I'm making the modeling
system open so that if people want to
know how are those predictions being
made they can know that's the other
thing I don't like about the proprietary
systems is most of them are using these
modeling approaches and when you say how
are you making that prediction they just
say trust us it works which is alchemy
it's not science so anyway so this was
just the data we have and then I was
going to just ask you to given this is
the data that we have given us the goal
that we have how would you use that
information what kind of representation
of that information would you make to
support a faculty member to change their
behavior that was that task so yeah
anybody who wants to work on that I have
a postdoc right now iris Holly who did
her PhD at Carnegie Mellon
and she actually already has her job her
assistant professor job lined up so I'm
losing her soon but this is her project
or right now anyway thanks
[Applause]
you